[Applaudissements]
je vais vous parler d'un pastis qui a
changé ma vie d'un vélo et d'un trésor
qui dort sous nos pieds
un vaste programme avec beaucoup
d'éléments je le conçois mais tous ces
éléments s'imbriquent dans une histoire
et cette histoire je vais vous la
raconter en 2013 obtention du bac devant
moi c'est le vide
comme la plupart de mes camarades je ne
suis animé par aucune passion
universitaire aucun métier de m'attire
et la vie d'adulte me terrifie lorsque
je choisis la faculté de biologie je le
fais parce que ça à côté de chez moi
avec ça a l'air super chouette d'être
étudiant bien je n'ai aucune idée de ce
que j'allais rencontrer et je n'ai pas
été déçu je me souviens de mon
professeur de biologie des organismes me
conter les aventures extraordinaires et
érotiques des vers de terre
ouah et quelle entrée en matière je vous
avoue j'ai pas appris grand chose
pendant ce court là excepté peut-être
comment reconnaître un mâle d'une
femelle vers de terre en même temps j'ai
aucun mérite ils sont hermaphrodites
ça me fait une belle jambe de savoir ce
à dire à quoi bon à quoi ça va me servir
plus tard je me posais plein de
questions
mais il ya bien il ya pourtant j'ai
arrêté de me poser ses questions et j'ai
obtenu ma licence
mais il ya pourtant bien une question
qui va changer ma vie c'est celle que me
pose mon pote nicolas un soir d'août
2013 et lucas est ce que ça te dirait de
faire un tour d'asie du sud-est en vélo
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout pas
du tout alors demain je n'ai pas de vélo
question pragmatique et de 2 depuis
quand on traverse des pays à vélo je
comprenais pas ça me dépasser et
pourtant si je suis là et pourtant et
pourtant c'est au cinquième pastis que
le projet va zy rouler n'est alors oui
nicolas sait être convaincant même si je
le soupçonne beaucoup d'avoir été aidé
par le pastis alors qu'est ce que ces
vases y roule et bien vas-y roule c'est
une association c'est nicolas et moi
c'est 6148 km sur les routes chaotiques
qui traverse le vietnam le laos le
cambodge et la thaïlande
c'est un point éducatif entre les
écoliers français de tout horizon social
et les écoliers asiatique en grande
difficulté financière
ces trois caméras de micros et de
reporters vas-y rôle c'est aussi mon
voyage initiatique
c'est mon voyage de sept mois a
bivouaqué en plein milieu de la jungle
du laos
c'est mon voyage à grignoter des rats
des cafards des fourmis et des crapauds
comme tombée par inadvertance dans ma
soupe c'est mon voyage à partager ma
couche avec une mygale c'est mon voyage
à rouler sur des pentes tellement pentue
que j'ai cru que j'allais définir en
rampant à côté de mon vélo en demandant
sincèrement si avec un ou deux pastis en
moi j'aurais été tranquillement dans mon
lit en train de bouquiner et de siroter
un thé
mais malgré ça va y roule ça a été
extraordinaire
nous avions fait le choix de ne pas
prendre de tenter de compter sur la
bonne volonté des gens pour nous
accueillir et nous n'avons pas été déçus
je me souviens des des modestes souper
partager avec les paysans demandent tech
marre des dizaines de gens rencontrés
vas-y rôle il m'a arraché mon confort et
il m'a ouvert les yeux c'est une
révélation pour moi je suis sorti du
schéma sociale conventionnelle et j'ai
suivi ma volonté et j'étais épanouie
j'ai trouver du sens à mes études de
biologie
grâce à une rencontre au bout de trois
mille kilomètres
nous arrivons chez les djalaï une
minorité ethnique du centre vietnam
cette minorité ethnique a la
particularité de vivre en parfaite
osmose avec la nature du moins autrefois
mais depuis quelques années ils ont
décidé de mettre leurs enfants à l'école
vietnamiennes afin qu'ils apprennent les
clés du développement et à s'ouvrir au
monde moderne
c'est ici que je parraine la petite mail
neuf ans depuis la mort de sa mère mais
il vit avec ses grands parents
autrefois riziculteurs il m'invite chez
eux ils vivent dans une petite maison de
20 m² à même le sol une dalle de béton
brut fracturée et gondoles et parler
période de mousson une date en guise de
salle à manger et de lits dans les coins
opposés
je rejoins la grand-mère qui m'explique
comment elle est passée de la culture du
riz à la culture des poivriers un jour
une société de micro finance leur a
proposé 1200 euros une somme colossale
pour les djalaï 1200 euros afin
d'emprunter pour planter des poivriers
pour eux c'est est la solution la
solution qui permettrait aux
grands-parents domaine de subvenir aux
besoins éducatifs de mail ça s'est pas
du tout passé comme prévu
ça a été une catastrophe car 75% des
poivriers sont morts au cours des deux
premières années dans l'impossibilité de
rembourser les grands-parents de mails
ont fait appel à une ong
c'est à ce moment que j'ai reçu le
dossier de parrainage dans la boîte aux
lettres je regardais la grand mère tout
y est sa soupe ça pourrait abîmer ses
yeux un peu reluisant par cette histoire
et les questions elle masai et pourquoi
les pauvres y y et de mails étaient
tellement le climat subtropical du
vietnam est très propice à cette culture
alors que s'était-il passé ces questions
elle me taraude jusqu'à mon retour en
france je peux vous dire que sur un vélo
est bon on a le temps de gamberger un
petit peu surtout avec 100 km par jour
aurait-on pu changer le cours de cette
triste histoire lorsque
je reviens en france je m'inscris au
masters planté société à tour un master
scientifique qui inclut la pédo biologie
l'étude de la vie des sols pédo ça veut
dire seul bio ça veut dire vivant et
logis c'est l'étude scientifique
on n'imagine pas en fait ce qui se passe
sous nos pieds toute la vie qui est
résident du coup je vous propose tous de
prendre vos pelles et d'aller voir ce
qui se passe sous nos pieds après
quelques coups de pelle voici le seul
typique que l'on pourrait trouver au
vietnam
alors maintenant imaginez imaginez un
gâteau un gâteau avec trois parfums
chocolat blanc chocolat au lait chocolat
noir et un glaçage à l'amande oui moi
aussi j'ai faim je vais pas encore
manger mais c'est pas l'heure est bien
le seul c'est pareil le sol ces trois
couches et une surface quatre
compositions différentes
sauf qu'il faut imaginer que ce gâteau
il s'imprègne de ses saveurs ils se
mélangent nos trois couches sont en fait
composé des mêmes éléments mais en
quantité totalement différente notre
couche duo notre glaçage lui est composé
de matière morte
il est composé de déjections de cadavres
d'animaux de feuilles
on va retrouver ses feuilles
cette matière morte dans notre couche de
chocolat noir mais cette fois en
décomposition c'est ce que l'on appelle
la matière organique
la matière qui provient du vivant plus
on va descendre vers notre couche de
chocolat blanc plus cette matière
organique va être remplacé par la
matière minérale qui ne provient pas du
vivant la matière inorganique
et donc elle provient de cette couche de
chocolat blanc qui est la roche et c'est
là où rentrent en jeu notre couche de
chocolat au lait notre couche de
chocolat au lait c'est la cohésion entre
la matière organique et la matière
minérale
c'est cette cohésion entre la match
vivante et la matière non vivante qui
permet un sol de retenir ces nutriments
de retenir l'eau alors vous allez me
dire d'accord mais comment elle fait la
matière pour bouger à l'intérieur du sol
et bien revenons-en à nos petites
bestioles du début de mon ted les vers
de terre
en fait nos vers de terre ce sont des
mini ascenseur
il absorbe la matière et l'art crash à
différents endroits dans le sol sous
forme de déjections il transporte
ils redescendent il remonte et il gère
le sol en y creusant des galeries les
vers de terre c'est un peu nos
ingénieurs du sol mais il ne travaille
pas tout seul il travaille main dans la
main enfin si je puis dire avec des
micro organismes et ces micro organismes
ils vont des composés notre matière
qu'elle soit organique ou minérales ils
vont faire de cette matière quelque
chose d' assimilables pour nos plantes
alors je simplifie bien sûr mais je n'ai
bien qu'il y ait des milliers d'espèces
de vers de terre et qu'il ya des
milliards de micro organismes pour vous
donner une idée une cuillère à café de
terre comporte plus de micro organismes
qu'il n'ya d'humains sur cette planète
alors maintenant que je vous ai donné la
la composition de ce gâteau je me doute
qu'il doit être un tout petit peu moins
appétissant pour vous ou alors faut
s'inquiéter
mais pour les plantes c'est un régal ça
c'est le gâteau qu'il faut
les plantes ont besoin de puiser via
leurs racines des nutriments et de l'eau
et bien c'est les vers de terre et les
micro organismes qui vont concocter
cuisiner ces nutriments
alors maintenant que vous êtes des total
expert en sol revenons-en à la
problématique de mais parce que c'est
pour ça que je suis ici au département
théoriquement le terreau est idéale au
vietnam pour planter des poivriers c'est
ce que je vous ai dit alors le sol
avait-il une constitution déséquilibré
pourquoi et est déséquilibré cette
constitution et bien je vous ai donné un
indice tout à l'heure les grands-parents
de mails étaient riziculteurs à la base
et le vietnam
c'est le deuxième plus grand exportateur
de riz pour avoir un titre pareil il
faut ajouter des outils technologiques
les engrais chimiques
les pesticides et un labour deux à trois
fois par an cette intensification de
cette agriculture
elle va entraîner plusieurs choses elle
va dérégler notre gâteau
premièrement nos micro organismes et nos
verres de terre ils vont disparaître ils
ne vont plus pouvoir exercer leurs
fonctions
cela entraîne un autre problème c'est
que notre couche de chocolat au lait va
disparaître tant est que la matière ne
peut plus être décomposé ne peut plus
bouger et bien il n'y aura plus cette
couche de chocolat au lait qui est
pourtant tellement importante pour la
plante c'est là où la plante vient
puiser ses nutriments et l'eau le sol va
s'appauvrir de ces nutriments l'eau va
s'en aller mais ce n'est pas
effectivement le seul problème
le deuxième problème c'est lors de
fortes pluies
lors de fortes pluies notre glaçage il
va s'en aller
pareil que notre matière organique pour
donner une importance de ce lessivage de
nos couches supérieures
et bien sachez que pour faire un
centimètre de sol il faut milan
et que d'après la fao l'organisation des
nations unies pour l'agriculture et
l'alimentation
33 % de nos sols sont gravement ou
modérément dégrader alors le but d'un
tête c'est pas de vous laisser sur une
idée négative
je peux vous laisser comme ça en plan je
vous donnais une solution l'une des
solutions envisagées
c'est de redonner justement à la terre
cette matière mans ce glaçage à la monte
et pour ça il faut limiter le labour il
faut limiter les engrais chimiques des
pesticides
ainsi on boostera on va booster notre
biodiversité la vie qu'il y a dans le
sol en boostant cette biodiversité on va
pouvoir trouver une couche de chocolat
au lait fonctionnelle une couche qui va
marcher
qui va retenir les nutriments qui va
retenir l'eau c'est ce à quoi s'est
attelée l'entreprise l'écologie une
entreprise californienne qui récolte les
ordures organique de san francisco et de
ses alentours
tenez vous bien ils peuvent produire 600
tonnes de compost par jour juste avec
ses déchets dp de biologistes aide les
agriculteurs du coin ils viennent sur
les terres et analyse le sol et ils
disent qu'elles sont les nutriments qui
manque à ce sol ensuite ils vont faire
un compost pour chaque terre différents
l'épée de biologie c'est un peu ce qui
qui font les élections de santé de nos
sols d'ailleurs dans 72 heures je
m'envole pour la guyane dans le cadre du
projet guyaz faire avec l'entreprise
solika ce projet ils comptent
sensibiliser les paysans à réduire le
labour les pesticides et les engrais
chimiques et à la place utiliser leurs
matières organiques qui n'utilisent pas
les déjections leurs épluchures
je vais tenter de chérir au maximum les
millions d'employés à ma charge
les vers de terre guyanais oublier ce
serait pas une renversante ironie ça
quand même
c'est ça c'est cette solution qui
permettra aux grands parents de mails de
redonner vie à ces poivrier qui
permettra d'avoir une récolte fructueuse
c'est le rôle de l'agroécologie c'est le
rôle de l'agriculture de demain
c'est notre rôle de redonner au sol sa
biodiversité
c'est ce qui permettra à mail d'aller à
l'école sans avoir besoin de mon aide
c'est ce qui permettra à meille d'aller
dans des facultés illustres ou des
professeurs de biologie des organismes
oui contre onze comment faire pour
améliorer la qualité de ses sols comment
faire pour améliorer la qualité de sa
communauté tout entière une vision à
long terme cette fois qui inclut la
nature le climat et la justice sociale
merci
[Applaudissements]